I know this morning your heart is in
Nashville what a nightmare Carrie
Underwood reacting to news of the
devastating tornadoes that hit her
Tennessee home town and surrounding
suburbs early Tuesday morning according
to authorities at least 19 people have
died across four counties and the number
of people missing is still unknown I
know we're still just calculating the
damage there I think that's what
everyone's doing right now is assessing
and I'm like texting people I know and
I'm like asking my husband like
everybody's good yeah the country
superstar also revealed how her hubby
former Nashville Predators star Mike
Fisher and their two sons five-year-old
Isaiah and one year-old Jacob
dealt with the deadly storms he said he
had to go upstairs at like 2:00 a.m. and
grab the boys and take him down to we
have like a little safe room in our
house and my god they were all right
everybody was crying
no it's 2:00 a.m. like freaking out tons
of other celebs are taking to social
media with their reactions to fellow
country singer Dierks Bentley posted
this terrifying video the 44 year old
singer revealed that he landed in
Nashville about an hour before the
tornadoes hit writing in part a lot of
people lost their homes including our
drummer and a lot of people in need but
no one comes together as a city like
Nashville does Maren Morris also had a
close call revealing on Instagram that
the storm must have missed her block by
an inch she went on to say that she and
her husband Ryan Hurd are alright and
are thinking of those who lost their
loved ones and home well I'm from here
it's great my whole family's here
Nashville native Reese Witherspoon
tweeted I'm just heartbroken and saying
special prayers for the families who
lost loved ones please stay safe and
Ryan Seacrest took to Twitter writing my
heart is with the entire community as
they recover from the devastation
meanwhile country singer Jake Owen
thanked everyone for their well wishes
writing
Nashville will stand together and help
anyone and everyone in need that's why
I'm proud to live here and call it home
well I'm here on the job today because
as they say the show must go on
but we had a lot of damage out in our
area despite being back at work Dolly
Parton took a moment to record this
message for those affected by the
tornadoes
I just wanted to shout out and say with
you
former Bachelorette Kaitlyn Bristowe who
lives in Music City with her boyfriend
Jason tardik this is not a drill
the best reveals that she used to live
two blocks from one of the most
devastated areas riding beautiful
neighborhood and amazing people
this is awful Nashville stars Connie
Britton and Charles esten also showed
their support for the southern city
connie tweeted sending so much love to
my nashville people after the tornado
stays strong and charles revealed that
while he and his family are safe our
hearts and prayers go out to those most
deeply affected and soon our hands well
nashville will rise and lift the broken
meanwhile miley cyrus posted this black
and white shot with the caption thinking
about my home and family in nashville
and how fortunate I am that my place and
loved ones have remained safe my heart
is broken for my home state we are
hashtag nashville strong and will
rebuild together
[Music]